and I knew this day was coming.
I wasn't expecting it at seven, I don't know why, but I wasn't.
Anyways, so I asked her, "How do you feel about that?"
So she proceeded to tell me,
and so any of you who are parents will recognize the bingo buzzwords here.
"The ships start in England, they come down from England,
they go to Africa, they go across the ocean --
that's the Middle Passage part --
they come to America, where the slaves are sold," she's telling me.
But Abraham Lincoln was elected president,
and then he passed the Emancipation Proclamation,
and now they're free.
Pause for about 10 seconds.
"Can I play a game, Mommy?"
And I thought, that's it? And so, you know,
this is the Middle Passage, this is an incredibly significant event,
and she's treating it like, basically some black people went on a cruise,
this is more or less how it sounds to her.
(Laughter)
And so, to me, I wanted more value in this,
so when she asked if she could play a game, I said, "Yes."
(Laughter)
And so I happened to have all of these little pieces.
I'm a game designer, so I have this stuff sitting around my house.
I said, "Yeah, you can play a game," and I give her a bunch of these,
and I tell her to paint them in different families.
These are pictures of Maezza when she was --
God, it still chokes me up seeing these.
So she's painting her little families.
So then I grab a bunch of them and I put them on a boat.
This was the boat, it was made quickly, obviously.
And so the basic gist of it is, I grabbed a bunch of families,
and she's like, "Mommy, but you forgot the pink baby
and you forgot the blue daddy
and you forgot all these other things."
And she says, "They want to go."
And I said, "Honey, no, they don't want to go.
This is the Middle Passage, Nobody wants to go on the Middle Passage."
So she gave me a look that only a daughter of a game designer would give a mother,
and as we're going across the ocean, following these rules,
she realizes that she's rolling pretty high,
and she says to me, "We're not going to make it."
And she realizes, we don't have enough food,
and so she asks what to do,
and I say -- remember, she's seven --
"We can either put some people in the water
or we can hope that they don't get sick
and we make it to the other side."
Just the look on her face came over --
now mind you this is after a month of --
this is Black History Month, right?
After a month, she says to me, "Did this really happen?"
And I said, "Yes." And so she said --
this is her brother and sister --
"If I came out of the woods, Avalon and Donovan might be gone."
"Yes."
"But I'd get to see them in America."
"No."
"But what if I saw them? Couldn't we stay together?"
"So Daddy could be gone."
"Yes."
She was fascinated by this, and she started to cry,
I started to cry, her father started to cry, and now we're all crying.
He didn't expect to come home from work to the Middle Passage, but there it goes.
And so, we made this game, and she got it.
She got it because she spent time with these people.
It wasn't abstract stuff in a brochure or in a movie.
And so it was just an incredibly powerful experience.
This is the game, which I've ended up calling "The New World,"
because I like the phrase.
I don't think the New World felt too new worldly exciting
to the people who were brought over on slave ships.
But when this happened, I saw the whole planet; I was so excited.
I'd been making games for 20-some years,
and then I decided to do it again.
My history is Irish.
So this is a game called "Síochán Leat." It's "peace be with you."
It's the entire history of my family in a single game.
I made another game called "Train."
I was making a series of six games that covered difficult topics,
and if you're going to cover a difficult topic, this is one you need to cover,
and I'll let you figure out what that's about on your own.
And I also made a game about the Trail of Tears.
This is a game with 50,000 individual pieces.
I was crazy when I decided to start it, but I'm in the middle of it now.
It's the same thing.
I'm hoping that I'll teach culture through these games.
And the one I'm working on right now, which is --
because I'm right in the middle of it,
and these for some reason choke me up like crazy --
is a game called "Mexican Kitchen Workers."
And originally, it was a math problem, more or less.
Here's the economics of illegal immigration.
And the more I learned about Mexican culture --
my partner is Mexican — the more I learned that,
you know, for all of us, food is a basic need,
and it is obviously with Mexicans, too, but it's much more than that.
It's an expression of love. It's an expression of --
God, I'm totally choking up way more than I thought.
I'll look away from the picture.
It's an expression of beauty, it's how they say they love you.
It's how they say they care,
and you can't hear somebody talk about their Mexican grandmother
without saying "food" in the first sentence.
And so to me, this beautiful culture,
this beautiful expression is something that I want to capture through games.
And so games, for a change, it changes how we see topics,
it changes our perceptions about those people in topics,
and it changes ourselves.
We change as people through games,
because we're involved, and we're playing,
and we're learning as we do so.
Thank you.